[Music]
you
[Music]
this video will help you understand a
heart attack and how to manage it please
watch the entire video to learn how to
manage your recovery if you have been
hospitalized with a heart attack it's
important to recover properly when you
return home a heart attack also called a
myocardial infarction or MI occurs when
blood flow to an area of your heart is
greatly reduced when the blood supply is
not able to keep up with the demand the
heart muscle cells don't get enough
blood to stay alive the result is death
of heart muscle cells in the affected
area of the heart
the goals after a heart attack are to
keep your heart healthy and avoid
another heart attack
recovery takes time and the amount is
different for each patient it depends
upon how much of your heart muscle is
damaged and your individual rate of
recovery you may also have had a
procedure this may also affect your
recovery time you can lower your risk of
having another heart attack by taking
these steps follow your doctor's
instructions make some lifestyle changes
and know when to seek medical attention
following the instructions of your
doctor and healthcare team is very
important to your recovery this includes
taking your medications exactly as
prescribed by your doctor don't stop
taking your medications or skip doses
take note of any side-effects and tell
your doctor
don't take any over-the-counter
medication or supplement without first
consulting your doctor
tell your doctor about any other
prescriptions you're taking some
medications can prevent your heart
medicine from working
it's important that your recovery is
monitored keep all of your follow-up
appointments have exams done as directed
by your doctor for example if your
doctor has told you to check your blood
pressure regularly do as directed
lowering your risk of another heart
attack usually requires some lifestyle
changes
limit your salt and sodium intake by
doing the following don't add salt when
you cook or - food at the table avoid
processed and fast foods compare food
labels and choose the items that are
lower in salt and sodium
heart-healthy diet including low fat low
cholesterol and high-fiber foods
a heart healthy diet helps you maintain
or achieve a good blood pressure and
weight it also helps prevent other
conditions that may further stress your
heart
limit your alcohol intake ask your
doctor if it's safe to include any
alcohol in your diet
maintain a healthy weight
don't smoke avoid all tobacco products
and secondhand smoke nicotine increases
heart rate and blood pressure at the
same time it decreases the amount of
oxygen rich blood delivered to your
body's tissues allow yourself time to
heal by taking it easy for the first
four weeks
getting a good night's sleep
resting in the afternoon
avoiding heavy lifting
and gradually increasing your physical
activity
ask your doctor when you can resume
driving sexual activity and return to
work
for weeks after your heart attack you
will begin cardiac rehab which includes
a closely monitored exercise regimen
after completing the cardiac rehab
program continue with regular exercise
through daily activities such as light
yard and housework
other good exercise options with your
doctor's approval are walking swimming
and bicycling as you exercise keep these
precautions in mind rest as needed stop
if you feel chest pain or have shortness
of breath and don't exercise when
temperatures are very hot or very cold
stress can affect your blood pressure
and your ability to maintain a healthy
lifestyle identifying the causes of your
stress and learning to eliminate or
manage them can help with your recovery
you may feel depressed discuss these
feelings with your doctor he or she can
prescribe medicine counseling or a
support group to help you adjust
it is important to stay aware of changes
in your symptoms and know when to get
help if your hospital stay included a
procedure with an incision check the
site each day for any signs of infection
call your doctor if you develop a fever
or redness heat pain tenderness
puss or bleeding at the incision site be
mindful of any symptoms of chest pain
pressure tightness heaviness ache or any
other kind of unusual sensation in your
chest as any of these could mean you
have a blockage in the blood vessels of
the heart symptoms related to blockage
in the blood vessels of the heart are
called angina and could be any one of
these symptoms angina symptoms may also
be felt in your arms
shoulders neck jaw
throat
or back
call your doctor if you think you're
experiencing angina
call 911 a of these symptoms angina that
doesn't go away with medication as
prescribed by your doctor
shortness of breath cold sweats nausea
vomiting or lightheadedness